say hello to Warren Buffett chairman CEO
of Berkshire Hathaway he joins us now
good to talk to you mr. Buffett have you
been what have you been to a Gustin I
actually have a member what is your best
round at Augusta not very good I think
it was probably at 89 that's my best
memory but it's a long time ago I I was
going to say I gave up golf but actually
golf okay but how important is golf in
your business with socializing like has
it replaced having dinners or lunches I
don't think so I it never really was I
I liked golf oh I played a lot of golf
when I was younger and and I it was a
factor in business for me I wasn't good
nobody wanted to play with me actually
is Bill Gates member at Augusta as well
he is a member in fact I was with him
when we were playing in a club
tournament and and on the very last shot
he hit was a hole-in-one and we played
the par-3 after the after the regular 18
and he knocked it in and it cost me
fifty five hundred dollars because the
foursome had to split boy I keep
reminding it helped me on this I'd
appreciate who's the most famous person
you play golf with well I played I
played with Tom Watson locally here one
time and I played on a high school team
at the same time that Arnold Palmer and
a fellow from Bethesda Chevy Chase
were the two best high school golfers in
the country so I saw those name was
Bubba Worsham his brother Lou Worsham
won the US Open one time
yeah they were 20 working brothers you
didn't play with Arnold did you I never
played with Arnold oh no but he and he
bubby changed as Arnold suggested he
change his name to buddy he didn't like
the name Bubba so they went to Wake
Forest together and actually Bobby
warship was killed in the car accident
down there and Arnold set up a
scholarship
I remember this honor yes yeah I have
had some correspondence I I had dinner
with Arnold one-time-only was and I
asked him what was his favorite
tournament and I thought it would say or
I thought it would say you know the
Masters and and maybe he would say the
British Open but but he named some
tournament where they they had five
rounds instead of four because Arnold
said if and they tournament went on long
enough he was going to win
he's Warren Buffett the chairman CEO of
Berkshire Hathaway and he's back with
his content give us the contest that you
have set up explain it to the audience
well we have a Berkshire about three
hundred and seventy thousand employees
about 10% of them are outside the
country but but during the tournament
everybody well everybody wants to fills
out a bracket last year we had 96
thousand people and then they obviously
don't pay anything to do it but if they
if they if anybody makes it through the
first round 32 games picking all the
winners and they're the only one they
get a million dollars if they get all
the way to the sweet 16 if they pick
they're all the winners in the first two
rounds they get a million dollars a year
for the rest of their life and this year
I just threw in that if Creighton wins
the whole thing we double the price so
so somebody somebody can win a million
last year we had going into the we had
five people that picked at least five
people to pick 31 out of 30 oh no every
and the one guy that was left at the end
he was in a game where his team was
leading at the at the half
and so even $100,000 I mean no matter
what happens the winner gets $100,000
tied we've got various systems for that
too but if you make it to the sweet 16
you can when you can win a million
dollars a year for the rest of your life
and and then our local companies all I
mean our subsidiary companies all have
or not all but good Miriam have their
own contest but this is the Berkshire
contest and it it generates a lot of
interest and I when I talked to the
winner last year he almost had done
better but I think I think is this under
somebody talk to him and do it so he
went a hundred thousand last year but if
the team I think some South Carolina
forget exactly who was playing but his
team was leading at the half and then
and then that he lost that game now
would have been for a million dollars
yeah you got the million instead of
hundred thousand I hope you win so sure
he's a good guy do you ever get tired to
talking about money well I know I but
you don't go to the when's the last time
you went to the ATM and and looked at
what was there or would there be that
much on if you went to the bank I I
never went I've never been to an ATM but
but I you know I keep a moderate amount
of money around but the excess I have I
keep in US Treasury bills so I don't I
don't keep lots of money in the bank
what kind of find anything checked about
lately though have you ever had a check
bounced
I don't think I've had a check well I I
gave my wife my first wife I gave her a
a t-shirt one time that could say that
said how can i how can I be overdrawn I
still have some checks left he was
pretty good at draining it out but I
can't recall being overdrawn but you
know probably have it at 87 you've done
everything did last time you called in
sick last time I call this sec hey I did
miss a day here a while back but I I
can't recall it's
that once actually that was a month ago
or so but I would say in the last five
years that's the only one I can recall
well that's pretty good yeah well in its
I
I like being in the office I'm down here
most Saturdays frankly all Saturdays
it's that's it's kind of quiet on
Saturday get a lot done last time you
talked to LeBron James it's been it's
probably been a year I went to a game
back there and that was the last time
maybe email we've had a couple of emails
he calls me uncle Warren I call him
nephew LeBron what about a business
decision to go to Los Angeles strictly
for the business part of it with LeBron
James not the basketball that's part of
it but how would you advise him if he
said you know the business of being in
Los Angeles well I don't know I would I
wouldn't give him much advice on that I
mean that's his business you know
essentially and I'm I don't give him a
lot of advice I'm cheering for him
basically and listen he's handled his
money so well I'm actually ready to
start out well I wondered about that now
with you know private planes and I do
have to be in you know you've been in
Omaha so did you ever did you ever feel
like you had to be in New York or Los
Angeles or London or anyplace else no
just the opposite I mean almost very
good if you're mainly traveling in the
United States I'm not much more than two
and a half hours from any place and so
almost a good place to be it's a good
place to be for a lot of other reasons
but but in terms of geographical
location it's it couldn't be much better
no I've I think I've done better because
I live in Omaha than if I lived in New
York I I lived in New York for a couple
years when I was in my 20s and that the
total of being there was I found I was
getting overstimulated I mean people
would call me with 20 ideas by noon and
you don't make money in the stock
business by by trading
actively or anything so it it's a little
quieter and I think that the decisions
are better I think in Omaha a little bit
better anyway
did they ever reach out to you on shark
tank no they haven't they haven't done
an on shark tank
they haven't with dancing on the Stars
okay if they called for shark tank or
Dancing with the Stars which one would
you accept well I I think I do shark
tank if they called me out Dancing with
the Stars I think I go in the federal
witness protection
[Laughter]
well Cuban did it and he went on he went
on both I know he's he's a lot got here
that I am he offered to be a Dairy Queen
manager one Oh Betty years ago so he
came up here a few years ago we went to
Dairy Queen that's competitive are you
oh I'm I've been pretty competitive all
my life I made but I think most people
are I mean it's no I like I like to win
but the trick with that is picking the
games you're in I mean it's you know the
way to be bobby fischer's to be to play
a many game except gel I think you've
won though
I think you've won one you won a lot of
games having fun it's always great to
talk to you continued great health and
good luck with the bracket challenge
again okay well let you know somebody
wins a million dollars Thank You Warren
alright that's Warren Buffett chairman
CEO Berkshire Hathaway this is four
years in a row we have him on and he's
just a he's just a treat just a treasure
great sense of humor for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
you